so a few years ago you wrote that
the cigarette is the deadliest object in
the history of human civilization
cigarettes kill about 6 million people
every year a number that will grow
before it shrinks
smoking in the 20th century killed 100
million people
and a billion could perish in our
century unless we reverse the course
can you
explain this
idea that it's the deadliest object in
the history of human civilization maybe
just
also talk about big tobacco and your
efforts there
well
cigarettes have killed more than any
other object than all the world of iron
all the world of gunpowder
nuclear bombs have only killed
a few hundred thousand people
cigarettes have killed hundreds of
millions
and every year kill about as many as
kovid
they're they're sort of neck and neck
but if you took the last five years
there's no contest
cigarettes have killed far more
and are far more preventable
so we're in a world this bizarro world
where every night there's a covid report
and cigarettes would never be mentioned
cigarettes would no more likely to be
mentioned than if we were talking about
chewing gum on a sidewalk they'd be no
more likely to be in a presidential
debate
than you know
sneezing in the wrong place
so
we live in this world where most things
are invisible
you know we
we are
the eyes are in the front of the head
we don't see what's behind us we have a
fovea which means not only do we only
see what's in front of us we see in a
very narrow tunnel
and that's because we're predators we
don't have the eternal watchfulness of
prey we have a zeroed targeted focus and
that leads to
a kind of myopia or a tunnel vision and
all kinds of things
then when you get something like a very
powerful tobacco industry which is a
multi-multi-billion dollar industry
which still spends
many billions of dollars advertising
every year but nonetheless manages to
make themselves invisible you have this
powerful agent that is producing
producing this engine of death
that
is invisible it's been reduced to the
fish that move themselves in other words
there's not really a tobacco industry
there's just people who smoke and that's
a personal choice like what food we're
gonna have for dinner tonight and
so it's erased from the policy world
it's as if it doesn't exist
and creating that sense of invisibility
to failure to understand the causes of
causes
is what allows the epidemic to continue
but
also not even to be acknowledged
the invisibility created is it natural
is it just human nature
that
ideas just fade
from our
attention or is it
malevolent still going on
kind of
um
action by the tobacco companies to keep
this invisible it's still going on
even when you see
an ad
against cigarettes on television
that's dramatically curtailed because
the
law that made those even possible
required that there be there's an
anti-villainy clause the industry can't
be made in
even visible in those ads and some they
get away with it but
the
industry operates through very powerful
agents you know powerful senators
they used to count uh
three-quarters of the members of of
congress as you know grade a contacts
they had most of the centers in their
pocket a lot of the senators sometimes
they'll play both sides of the aisle
basically tobacco is democratic
democratic party
until
basically
the 70s and ronald reagan then it shifts
over to becoming
republican
they
create bodies like the tea party
they merge with big oil
the koch brothers
in the
1980s and 90s to form the tea party and
a whole series of fronts which
fight against all
regulation and all taxation in order to
prevent
gas taxes and cigarette taxes
which are bonded in the convenience
store
and walmart most cigarettes are actually
sold in places like walmart and
pharmacies and
7-elevens things like that
and through that locus then you have
gasoline and tobacco sort of in this
micro architectural collaboration
uh so there's multiple multiple means
that they use plus a lot of their
targeting is is is hyper specific
they use the internet very effectively
they use email and thing that are
customer
customer targeting
what goes to the mind of a big tobacco
executive
this is connecting to our previous
conversations of scientists and so on
i always wonder about that i
talked to pfizer ceo for example
and there's a deep question with the
pfizer ceo
with with i i guess any ceo but big
pharma
would you
it's like if you can come up with a cure
that gets rid of the problem
that's in the big pharma
would you want to because
you're going to lose a lot of money once
the cure fixes the problem it's nice to
like there's so many incentives to make
money
can you think clearly and make the right
decisions i'd like to believe most
people are good and
it's almost like this steve jobs idea
just like do the right thing
and you'll make money in the end
it's like long term you'll make a lot of
money if you do the right action because
there's always going to be problems you
can fix you can always pivot the company
to focus on other things as long as
you're doing the best innovation the
best science the best development and
the
production and deployment and stuff
you're going to win
but there's another view where you might
that kind of idea of making money
pollution is the widget building it it's
exciting when you can release a product
that makes a lot of money
and you start enjoying the charts that
say the money is going up
and you stop thinking about maybe
there's the
that's the wrong choice for human
civilization well one of the reasons i
was made a
courtesy appointment in pulmonary
medicine
at stanford was they recognized i was
doing more to save lives
by trying to stop big tobacco than they
were by yanking out
this lung that lung you know on a daily
basis cause of causes the cause of
causes which i which we can keep
returning to
your question about
how do people live with themselves is a
crucial one and
it's one i've thought about a lot it's
one you think about with in in any
context of horror
how do people live with themselves how
do they get up
in the morning
i think there's a lot of incentives
one thing that
you have to keep in mind is that
whoever becomes ceo of a big tobacco
company
they have already made decisions along
the way and they are the remnant
of a whole series of aspiring
people who want to climb the ladder of
success who maybe would refuse
yeah something like this but those don't
survive the journey those survive the
journey who be who can make it through
and and i think they have a mixture of
ideologies one they'll say well if i
didn't do it someone else would
this is kind of the poor the cyclone be
down the chimney into auschwitz well if
i didn't do it
someone else would so what's really the
difference between me doing someone else
so
that's one view another one is
the tobacco industry i think really
doesn't like their customers except for
the fact that they like their their
money
when you look at their documents they
talk about target targeting against
young adults or against women or against
uh
homosexuals there's a whole project
reynolds has called
project scum which is project
subculture urban markets where they're
targeting homeless and homosexuals in in
san francisco so what kind of business
model regards their customers as as scum
or talks about them
uh as as
as one famous
reynolds executives you know we don't
smoke this stuff we reserve that for the
poor the black and the stupid
that's a direct quote
uh from one of the winston models so
it's a company culture that sees the
customers almost like
as the enemy or like uh or worthless
losers losers you know so you have
these executives
you know if we don't do it someone else
will
if people are dumb enough to buy our
product right let them buy it
maybe it's a personal choice maybe
they're libertarians
maybe they're just
as you said seduced by the money and the
money is enormous the money is enormous
in these these the you know tobacco
executives make tens of millions of
dollars per year just in their salaries
um i so i think there's a whole series
of of logics some at some point some of
the companies have become food producers
in the 1980s and 90s philip morris which
makes marlboro was the largest food
producer in the united states
and so
they could say well we're producing many
products many
addictive desirable desirable products
i think one project i'm working on now
actually is looking at how the industry
maintains morale in their own workforce
and they create a kind of parallel world
of prizes and rewards and
tobacco queens and tobacco princesses
and tobacco sports teams and tobacco
it's this whole separate world a world
within a world and
we all live in bubbles of a sort and so
there is this kind of tobacco world
where
you're with us or you're against us
and i even found evidence that the
tobacco
industry lies to its own employees so
they
censored their own
employee information so that everyone
would be on board that well maybe it
doesn't really cause cancer the evidence
is all statistics
can't trust mice experiments because
mice are not men
they hire the guy
darrell huff who wrote how to lie with
statistics the best selling statistics
book in the history of the world
they paid him to write a book called how
to lie about smoking with statistics
now that was never published
uh when when sort of word of some other
dirty tricks got out
so
one way they're able to
gain legitimacy gain normalcy
gain you know these are supporters of
the arts you know there are universities
named
for
tobacco executives you know we have duke
university and we have the george
weissman school i think is of arts and
sciences at cuny
and
there are uh prizes you know philip
morris essentially created women's
tennis as a spectator sport billie jean
king
joins the board of directors of philip
morris
she signs coupons the two to one coupons
for buying virginia slim cigarettes
so the industry is able to acquire this
talent
and then through a kind of a
an application of causality purely into
the individual smoker if you smoke you
did it to yourself
and so
in a sense we have nothing to do with it
it's sort of the same argument
exxon is making now with uh carbon it's
like well we just make the gas we don't
burn the gas so really we're not the
problem it's it's whoever drove here in
a car that burned gas
and
so there's a very interesting question
how who who is liable who is responsible
for
is the manufacturer just immune because
it's a legal product and people make the
foolish decision to smoke
or does the addiction play a role in the
liability so these are all really
interesting legal questions and
philosophical questions
where do you attribute the success in
the fight against big tobacco so i mean
there's been a lot of progress made
maybe two questions one is that and two
how much more is to be done
well there's been in my view not that
much progress
to the tobacco industry basically won
the war
against cigarettes in the 1950s
the broader assumption inside and
outside the industry would be what was
that
if tobacco is if cigarettes are ever
shown as causing cancer obviously
they'll be banned
the famous slogan in the 50s was if if
spinach
were ever shown to cause one-tenth the
harm of cigarettes that would be banned
overnight
flash forward you know 50 years we still
have
uh 300
[Music]
we still have 200 some billion
cigarettes smoked in the united states
every year
globally we still have
about six trillion cigarettes smoked
every year that's 350 million miles of
cigarettes smoked every year
that's enough to go to make a continuous
chain of cigarettes from the earth to
the sun and back
with enough left over for several round
trips to mars but it's much fewer than
before i mean okay so culturally
speaking
i grew up in soviet union
uh everybody smoked
everybody smoked well by everybody you
mean about half well by everybody i mean
culturally so
so what does it feel like when everybody
smokes right what percentage is that
right now in the united states it feels
like nobody smokes feel i'm talking
about culturally do you see
uh famous actors and actresses
do you see movies all the time you do
you can't watch a hollywood movie
without
pretty much continuous smoking but i
mean look at peaky blinders look at
uh you know any of the modern series now
it's pretty much a one non-stop
you're right there has been a change i
mean that's true the the purest metric
in the united states is number of
cigarettes smoked per year and that
peaks in 1981
at 640
billion cigarettes wow that's declined
now to the level it was in 1940
which is about 240
billion cigarettes wow now globally the
number has increased
see but but the perception and sorry to
interrupt but the
that's interesting even in the united
states the numbers the decrease is not
as significant as i thought it is
because
just in my own experience with people
you know people speak negatively about
smoking yeah well for one thing smokers
do i mean smokers hate the fact they
smoke right so this this is the
interesting observation i'm speaking to
is
uh even the smokers
are talking negatively about smoking but
they're still smoking so even though i'm
seeing this shift where smoking is no
longer the cool thing
where it's uh like when i was growing up
and i smoked for a time it was like a
way to bond with strangers
to uh to talk to you
share a moment and share a moment
together i mean it's a beautiful thing
and it it's it's interesting because we
need to find other ways to share moments
uh but you know obama you almost smoked
from a stranger i mean
that was seen as a good thing now did
you ever smoke
oh yeah for how many years uh
two years i was in music so
what happened is i was a musician i was
in a band well there you go and
no there is a bonding aspect to it and i
think i stopped smoking when they
uh banned
um smoking inside bars yeah exactly
which was uh i mean that was
i mean looking back now it seems
it's such a powerful move i mean maybe
you can speak to that because
that was one of the moments that woke me
up wait a minute
like um that was a big shift for me and
i'm sure i'm not alone where
it's not just
like
it forced me to rethink the the effect
of smoking has on me yes and also to
think can i actually live a life without
smoking can i
um you know some people have that i
haven't i haven't gone through that
process yet but some people have that
with drinking yeah can i have fun
without drinking
um i think the answer to that is yes but
i'm still drinking
[Music]
so that that's a big shift for example
if they
ban drinking at certain places and
there's a lot of negative things to say
about alcohol well i'm i'm older than
you and i remember when
mother and i think you weren't even in
the in this country then but there was
something called mothers against drunk
driving
and if you look at movies from the 50s
60s
even 70s being drunk was just kind of a
funny thing yeah and you would drive
drunk
what's the big deal really and mothers
against drunk driving really
denormalized
drinking and driving much like seat
belts when i was a kid you know there
were no seat belts you just lie in the
back of the car and you drove out west
with your with your parents and you'd
lie flat it was wonderful seat belts
come along and now it's pretty
normalized that you buckle up it's
pretty normalized that you don't drink
and so the moment you identify is
absolutely crucially important a lot of
it started in california
where
there were bands on
on cigarettes some of it actually
started in the computer industry because
some of the early bugs that were found
on tapes in the 70s were caused by smoke
and some of the earliest indoor smoking
bans were actually in computer rooms
which were supposed to be clean enough
that the tapes wouldn't spin and get
caught by some
snag of soot
and the workers started saying wait a
minute if
if the smoke can hurt the tapes
can it hurt my lungs as well and so some
of these early laws already in the late
70s early 80s
pushing it out it was a huge struggle
the tobacco industry marshaled an army
of experts
to say that second-hand smoke is an
entirely different kind of smoke it
can't hurt you they they eventually lost
that battle
and now we have so-called smoke-free
laws
where you can't smoke
in most workplaces in most restaurants
and
that denormalization has been crucial
because remember aristotle says tell me
who you walk with and i'll tell you who
you are
and if your friends are smoking if your
friends are
doing whatever it it makes it easier
the tobacco industry has been a genius
at manipulating and really creating the
material culture of the modern world
if your shirt has a pocket
that's to fit cigarettes
right if your car has a has a plug in
every car that that i used to have had a
cigarette lighter it had an ashtray
every plane that i flew when i was a kid
when i was younger anyway
there was smoking on it originally
and then there were ashtrays
and even today
every plane by law has to have ashtrays
in the bathrooms because people still
smoke in the planes
there's a special technique they have
where they go in and
light up your cigarette and put your
mouth right down in the middle of the
toilet and then flush it right at that
same moment
and that's why they're i think it's a
good big puff
good big puff and flush it
and to prevent people from bringing down
the plane by putting the cigarette out
in the trash
every plane must have ashtrays
so that tells you something about the
power of addiction the power of normalcy
and it's related to your question of
this this crucial moment if you can no
longer smoke in a bar if you can no
longer smell and by the way that's
different from drinking
most people who smoke
wish they didn't
most people to drink that's not true
most people who drink they don't wish
there are some addicts you know five
percent we say
but you're talking about 70 80 90
percent of people who smoke cigarettes
regularly or wish they did not and
that's actually where i learned about
uh
the idea that we could get rid of
cigarettes entirely was just from
talking to ordinary smokers those are
the people
who
are willing to say you know let's let's
get let's get cigarettes all together
and get rid of them all together because
it's not a recreational drug it's very
different from alcohol and the genius of
of the out of the tobacco industry is to
turn
basic to trivialize addiction into just
something we all like
it's addictive i like it
and also to say that basically smoking
is like drinking which in fact it's not
alcohol tends to be a recreational drug
and
cigarettes are more like heroin
so
how do we get that 200 billion down
closer to zero
well the good news and i know you like
good news and i i do too
is that every year
we have about eight billion fewer
cigarettes smoked in the united states
so
we're going in the right direction
we're going to solve this you know there
not every problem you can solve in the
world this is a very solvable problem
it's an enormous problem arguably as big
as covid in certain respects
much more invisible than covet
but very solvable and actually will be
solved probably because of of of climate
change because we're going to need to
find ways to
reduce carbon footprints across the
board and that's going to be a
a kind of uh
cultural revolution of sorts
once we have a category 6 hurricane and
you know
hundreds of thousands of people start
dying from the
storms that are coming
but will be it's like that metaphor of
you know there
there's a
a sci-fi film from 1950 where they're
trying to uh get back to earth from the
moon and uh they have to jettison their
toolbox and their ladder and this and
this and this that's sort of i think
where the world we're going to be and
we're going to have to jettison a lot of
things and cigarettes will be
one of the things we can get rid of
you